montréal est reconnue pour son stade ses
mythes bull sont orange julep et sédégo
a le plaisir de savourer un bep go to
show à sa sortie du four le bigot de
montréal est reconnue partout à tel
point qu'on parle du bégo style mourir
c'est un mégot artisanale qu'on mange
surtout frais il y a aussi le bigot
style new york plus gros et dont la
préparation diffère du premier la
boulangerie saint viateur bégaud prépare
depuis 1957 c'est bégaud de style
montréal depuis quelques années des
milliers sont livrés dans les épiceries
partout au québec et même ailleurs nous
c'est vraiment le four à bois
ils sont mouillés dans l'eau avec du
miel qui s'essaye son roulé à la main
c'est vraiment artisanale de montréal en
épicerie on trouve des bigots style
montréal clairement identifiés mais on
trouve surtout ce style new york qui ne
porte aucune mention particulière avec
les différentes saveurs
on en compte plus d'une trentaine de
variétés mario fortin et consultant en
boulangerie il préfère son mégot avec du
fromage à la crème
qu'est ce qui donne le goût du vélo de
montréal j'ai justement le fait de le
bouilli avec soin du miel ou du mal dans
l'eau on va chercher un petit goût et
mélanger avec la saison qui colle bien
au dessus donc ça mène
un bon goût et ce surtout caractérisée
par le bout de la saison guy le vélo de
montréal alors que le bigot new york lui
façonner aussi mais mécaniquement par
des machines parce qu'on en fabrique en
plus grande quantité mais c'est big lots
sont cuits dans des fous avec va pas moi
les vegas est quelque chose que je
mangeais chaque jour quand j'étais petit
et chaque fois que je mangeais même les
prisons jefferies finkelstein et
boulanger sur le boulevard saint laurent
à montréal
il préfère son mégot rôti avec du beurre
il n'en vend pas mais les aime tous moi
les beaux gosses et comme des pizzas
c'est quand même tout dépit de ça sent
bon pour moi j'adore tout mais c'est
vrai il y a des - ben et des super pour
notre évaluation nous avons choisi les
classiques aux césars de marque country
harvest gadois comme compliment
sélection sans nom in et oies et deux
styles montréal schifrin kick et
saint-viateur tous deux disponibles en
épicerie mais la belle couleur d'un
mégot pour moi c'est ça c'est l'illustré
est bien dorée donc on voit aussi la
déposition des sésames qui est très
différente
ceux ci sont fait mécaniquement il y en
a pas en dessous sont juste eu le dessus
alors que ceux là sont roulées dans ces
âmes dont on en voit qu'il n'a pas tout
pour moi le bigot montréal un meilleur
goût mais n'a pas durée de vie oui alors
que le bacon new york le feq été tué
comme un pain une plus longue
fermentation donc on va les chercher un
7/7 jours durée de vie jusqu'à cinq
jours dans le cas des bigots artisanaux
c'est aussi parce qu'il ya on n'a pas de
l'additif l'op
c'est ça la plupart ne m'aide pas aussi
d'inhibiteurs de mesures dans aucun
hargne et pau préserver la fraîcheur le
long terme sens moins seul dans calais
bègles industrielle on trouve une longue
liste d'ingrédients et des agents de
conservation pour en prolonger la durée
de vie
certains vont rajouter le vinaigre ou
vinaigre de cidre de pomme
qui pour moi un ennemi temps qui est
naturel mais c'est surtout du
proprionate de calcium du sorbate de
potassium de l'acide sorbique ou de
l'acide fut maric que l'on utilise les
pommes on peut sentir et les agents de
consommation parce que c'est on
s'intéresse à sciez donc on s'en lasser
de fumeurs est sûrement il y a des gens
qui mettent des trucs acide de danse et
la civic et ça ça aide à conserver aussi
mais à la même temps pour moi j'aime les
mais les listes d'ingrédients de plus
simple pas si celui ci aux moyens
textures un peu plus fin et moins dense
que les autres qui fait la
caractéristique temps bégaud ça pour moi
la part de taxe ursin peut pas bego
bégaud et plus fins et plus par le petit
trou comme ça c'est souvent un bureau
qui a fermenté a peut-être un petit peu
tôt a longtemps donc il y aura fermé
vers le centre même salle le goût est
bon mais c'est quand même parle et
l'intérieur c'est moins intéressant ce
sas est plus parvenu parce que le goût
est important ce musée c'est un peu
sucré si on regarde c'est le cas il ya 4
g de sucre qui est plus créé à la base
la cuisson comme ça dans un grille pain
ça ajoute kouao bega sa valeur chercher
un petit peu une souplesse sur bégaud
parce qu il durcit en vieillissant on
peut voir que moins de chutes parce que
ça crée alors beaucoup moins et c'est ce
qui fait aussi que à l'extérieur alors
un peu plus et lui il ya du mal d'outils
miel dedans donc ça faire un peu plus de
collaboration et ça il y avait un bon
groupe de deux salles de dents et j'aime
ça aussi ça c'est un des plus salées
aussi certains bégaud cache en effet
plus de 400 mg de sodium par petits
pains
c'est le cas de gars doit country
harvest et sans nom salom peu plus
sentais un peu plus comme de pain brun
ou pas intégral si c'est bio fac oui tu
as raison
en termes synthèse format celui qui est
le plus complet
bon ça c'est plus artisanale on peut
voir que les trous sont bien différents
pas trop réguliers et je vois aussi un
peu brûlé ici tu peux voir des petits
charbon ça c'est alors que c'était cuit
dans un four de voix sans surprise notre
testeur a préféré le bigot saint viateur
mais il a aussi apprécié gadois
compliment est signé ouah ça c'est
intéressant peut-être c'est pas bégueule
3,6 et leurs bases et de tous les autres
mais à beaucoup des saveurs différentes
dedans je suis content et je pensais
c'est cool d'avoir des produits
que devient plus en plus mieux avec le
temps
avant il y a dix ans dans le supermarché
c'était vraiment pas bon il n'y avait
pas des options que vous préfériez les
bégueules style new york ou montréal
nos experts ont un dernier conseil moi
ce que je suggère ce qu'aiment les
acheter chaud ou frais ben quand
j'allais tout de suite et par la suite
mais vous le faites réchauffer ou le
sorteo météo grille pain et ça donne
quelque chose de merveilleux parce qu'il
va encore tout son moelleux
quand même c'est aussi qu'est-ce que tu
mettes dessus se débandent beurre du
fromage de fromage à la crème de de
saumon fumé moi j'enlève le centre je
remplis travail ce que je couds pas à
pas
la farine fromage comme ça et pelle je
ne suis pas prêt qu'à la fin est
toujours second
[Musique]